and finally new rule America must ask
itself this question what do we do about
the easy access to firearms by young men
who simply feel like [ __ ] there's no
shortage of reasons offered as to why
America has a gun violence problem but
isn't it a lot of it because America is
an every man for himself winner-take-all
culture that chews up and spits out
people who don't keep up you can fly as
high as you want here but if you fall by
the wayside
our response is sucks to be you loser
unfollow you want a friend get a gun 42%
of the people in America make $15 an
hour or less how much of a life can you
really have on that budget what is an
American mass shooter really but a
suicide bomber wearing Axe body spray
the nra should change its slogan to guns
don't kill people seething loners who
can't get laid kill people
yes we have too many guns but America
has an epidemic of gun violence be good
has because it has an epidemic of guys
who were picked last in gym I do it for
them at home forget red flags just find
the guys who cut their own bangs
I know profiling is wrong but if a guy
takes his mother to the prom he goes on
the list does your fondest sexual memory
involve to other people you heard
through a wall
[Applause]
the last thing I do you've been selected
for extra screening armed and lonely is
not a good combination
America has a loneliness crisis 22
percent of Millennials say they don't
have any friends
25 percent say they don't even have an
acquaintance 10 percent didn't know that
pizza comes in slices so someone else
can have some
[Music]
and what is it that has made people so
lonely it's their stupid phone which
we're supposed to connect people
but which studies have found has made
them more lonely it's like a vibrator
designed by Mike Pence
[Applause]
the internet is where young white men go
from lonely and sad to radicalized and
lethal because we used to wake up read
the paper see all the terrible things in
the world and say oh well at least my
life is better than those poor slobs but
now it's the opposite
social media tells you everyone is
having more fun with more toys and more
friends than you they're always in st.
Kitts having mai tais at sunset
well you're in Canoga Park selling your
plasma at dusk before Instagram you
could be a loser but not feel it because
the winners weren't always in your face
even the most mundane post of avocado
toast in a hipster coffee shop sends the
message I'm having fun and you're not
enjoy your cup of noodles fatty this is
how the Internet gets you coming and
going guys watch the haves on Instagram
and then go over to sites like 8chan to
brood with the have-nots being a loser
used to just mean that you stayed home
on Friday nights to get a head start on
your Star Wars fan fiction you had a
hard dick and no social skills
but it wasn't a movement but now hookah
sites like 8chan it is a Chan is where
three of the mass shooters so far posted
their manifestos it's where queuing on
got started a Chan is too lonely white
man what the Hometown Buffet is to
gastric bypass patients
both dangerous and inescapable and it's
why people need real friends not
chatroom friends not Facebook friends
not fellow paranoids feeding each other
misinformation on a screen but real
human friends who can look you in the
eye and tell you that your theories
about the coming race war or horseshit
and to tell you that social media isn't
real so stop comparing yourself to a
fantasy no one is having that much fun
they're just distorting reality too big
themselves up trust me anyone out there
who's home tonight feeling left out
discarded and disrespected if you knew
how much everybody else is faking it you
wouldn't want to join them anyway
[Applause]
you